we're told that phlox is a skydiver on
the planet lernon
the function a of w is equal to 0.2
times w squared gives the area a in
square meters under flux's parachute
when it has a width of w meters that
makes sense
the function v of a is equal to the
square root of 900 over 980 over a gives
flux's maximum speed in meters per
second when she skydives with an area of
a meter a square meters under her
parachute all right
write an expression to model flux's
terminal velocity when her parachute is
w meters wide and then they want us to
evaluate the terminal velocity when her
parachute is 14 meters wide well let's
just focus on the first part first pause
the video and see if you can have a go
at that
all right now let's just think about
what they're asking us they want us to
model terminal velocity when her
parachute is w meters wide so really
what they want us to do is come up with
a terminal velocity let's call that v
that is a function of w that is a
function of the width of her parachute
well we have a function here that gives
terminal velocity as a function of the
area of her parachute but lucky for us
we have another function that gives us
area as a function of
width
and so we could say this is going to be
the same thing as v of
this function right over here i'll do
another color
a
of w
and so that is going to be equal to
let me keep the colors consistent well
everywhere where i see an a in this
expression i would replace it with a of
w which is 0.2 w squared so it's going
to be equal to the square root of 980
over instead of a i am going to write so
instead of this i am going to write 0.2
w squared because that is a as a
function of w
0.2
w squared so this right over here this
is an expression that models flux's
terminal velocity v as a function of the
width of her parachute so that's what we
have right over there
and then the next part they say what is
flux's terminal velocity when her
parachute is 14 meters wide
well then we just have to say okay w is
14 let's just evaluate this expression
so we'll get the square root of
980
over
0.2
times
14 squared
well 14 squared is 196
and this would be equal to the square
root
of
see 980 divided by 196 i believe is
exactly five so this would be five
divided by zero point two and so five
divided by essentially one fifth is the
same thing as five times five so this
would be the square root of 25 which is
equal to five and the terminal velocity
since we gave the width in meters this
is going to give us the maximum speed in
meters per second so 5
meters per second and we're done